the first person I came out to was God
and the first conversation I ever had
about this with anybody was in prayer
for me God and Jesus and the Holy Spirit
have always been my closest friends in
this journey it's funny I have never
really quite put it like that before so
when people tell me how can you be
openly gay and Catholic my response is
now and always has been I'm openly gay
because I'm a Catholic because my
conscience really and it was it was not
an easy decision it was a struggle for a
long time as very precocious kid thought
a lot about this prayed a lot about and
was was was because I really believe it
it's my more responsibility as a
Christian to tell the truth because I do
not believe that the truth can ever be
in conflict with God and I think a lot
of people are afraid the truth is in
conflict with God and and on on able to
let go and let the truth of the world I
mean as john paul ii put it the one
thing jesus tells everybody he ever
meets in the gospels the most common
thing he ever says be not afraid and
homophobia were the internalized or
externalize is is really fear it's not
hatred it's fear it's fear of the truth
about ourselves so and the first person
I think I actually told that I was
actually going to have an emotional or
sexual relationship with a priest I went
to confession and said bless me Father
for I'm about to sin I did it
preemptively because I knew at some
level I didn't really think it was a sin
then having done it and having entered
that world boy was a not a sin it was
was a form of such lung feeling life
that such an obvious blessing from God
that on its it was absurd I mean not
that a homosexual connotes it not that I
haven't seen not that not that there are
some aspects of sex there are so
powerful that they obliterate from our
minds even an understanding a sense of
the presence of God in that sense
because they take us away from him they
can be sinful but I mean by sin simply
forgetting God because this stuff is so
awesome on the other hand I also believe
that there are moments in saks that are
so awesome that they are to the reflect
God so I seen in conflict but to return
to the basic question so the first
person I came out to was God the second
person I came out to was a priest who
himself of course was gay because
they're barely any who aren't and then
my parents and my family and I I went
home and I to England and I I asked my
mom and dad to sit down together to have
a conversation with me which is
something I had actually never done
before and they were kind of a little
perplexed by this and so I sat them both
down living room and I said I just want
to have a conversation with you both at
the same time I'm gay I always have been
and I always will be and I'm happy and
my mother I mean he's very English
people or my mother is also I mean the
English but Irish in origin and and my
mother's devoutly Catholic she just said
what does that mean I said I'm gay I'm a
homosexual I finally decided I want to
go well I think she was still grabbing
on to various forms of etymology at that
point and then she said in classic
English fashion oh my god I better go
make a cup of tea
this was her literal response through
this question and she left the room to
make tea which is what the English do
when all hell breaks out because you
know it's a ritual you know what to do
and my father who is and was like a big
jock captain of his rugby high school
team captain of our town's rugby team a
real man's man
English reserved bent double and started
solving which kind of took my breath
away and I said to him daddy and you
know why are you crying I'm okay I'm
really okay it's okay I'm happy I'm fine
he carried on with sea life forever
I'd never you know I'd never seen my
father cry he'd only ever cried once
before according to lore which was when
Kennedy was shot and killed and then
when he's our mother died ah
at least that's family I'd him I don't
know that's literally true but finally I
said well can you tell me why you're
crying so I can respond to it and he
looked at me in the eyes and he said I'm
crying because of everything you must
have gone through when you were growing
up and I never did anything to help you
which is which some of the most
beautiful words anybody has ever said to
me in my life and then I was Iraq and my
father has been a rock for me ever since
and again
it's a long time ago but it's funny how
when you say it again you remember how
painful that was and how cathartic it
was and how and how tough it still is
for so many people and how much pain and
misery that is still inflicted on so
many people in the world and we've been
reminded of it recently by these ghostly
suicides this horrible torture in the
Bronx Queens but I guess at a bottom so
to speak I believe that that was a
moment of grace that my father's ability
to transcend so much was was was was God
intervening and lifting us up to a
better place and and therefore all these
things that are supposed to be
contradictions within me and within many
other people or not they are actually
just things we don't yet fully
understand